- Hi everyone, welcome
to our daily homeroom.
I'm very excited about
the guests we have today
and before we we jump into
that conversation I will give
my standard announcement.
Remind everyone that Khan Academy is
a not-for-profit organization.
That we could only exist
with philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position
to do so please think
about donating to Khan Academy.
I wanna give a special shout
out to several corporations
who've helped support us
especially when they found out
that we're running at a
deficit pre-COVID and then
because of COVID our
server costs have gone up,
we've been trying to accelerate
a whole series of programs.
So special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly and Novartis.
So with that I'm really
excited to introduce
our next guest, James Manyika.
I have many connections
and there's many reasons
why James is interesting.
I consider him a friend, a
mentor, he is also a board member
of Khan Academy and his day
job is he is the Head of
the McKinsey Global Institute.
So James thanks for joining us.
May be a good place to start
is for those who don't know,
McKinsey or the McKinsey
Global Institute, what is that?
- Well thank you Sal I'm
so delighted to be here.
It's one of those situations
where I feel like you're
one of my teachers.
It's kind of like when you
teacher invite you to class
and you're kind of terrified
because they've been your teacher,
so I'm kind of a little
terrified right now
but I'm delighted to be here.
- James is being so humble.
He knows which way the mentorship
goes in this relationship.
- No but, so thank you for having me.
So the McKinsey Global Institute
is kind of McKenzie's economics
and research, think-tank
if you like.
So we research trends in
the economy, the impact
that technology is having on society.
We look at issues around
economic growth, inequality,
globalization, so these
are trends we spend
a lot of time thinking about
and we try and make our views
kind of benefit leaders
where there's leaders
in the private sector, in
business, in non-profits
in government, many of those folks
around the world take advantage
of the research that we do.
- So what I'm hoping to
talk to James about I think
there's many things we
could talk to him about
but directly related to his
work and he obviously sits on
the board of Khan Academy
and several other foundations
I'd love to dive into, even
pre-COVID James has done
a lot of interesting work around
the future of work and what
will technology and automation do to it.
There's then a layer that
COVID has added to it,
then there's a layer of the
environment we're in around
the anti-racism movement,
how do we increase diversity,
equity and inclusion in
corporations and then what things
might transcend beyond
the COVID crisis or beyond
the new cycle that we happen to be in.
So if anyone has any questions
on YouTube or Facebook
please put your questions
in the message boards.
We have team members
who are looking at them
and they'll surface those
questions to myself and James.
But James just to get everyone
grounded, given the work
that you just described that
the McKinsey Global Institute does
what, even pre-COVID, what
trends have you seen or
are you all prognosticating
about the future of work?
What is automation going to do?
What is globalization or
de-globalization going to do?
- Well I think work has been
changing and will continue
to change in some profound
ways and I think there are
a few different things that
are driving those changes.
The first one is the role of
technology and automation.
We know that this moment this is a trend
that's been going on
for centuries actually.
Every time we've invented new
ways or technological ways
to complement what people
do, the work that people do
there's always been this
ongoing kind of tension
and coevolution between what
people do and what the machines
around them to do, so
the role of technology
and automation is one of those
trends that affects work.
The other trend that's been
affecting work is the fact that
there are now many more varieties of work.
So we know that there are
people who do full-time jobs,
there are people who
now do independent work,
the gig economy.
So the set of arrangements
that we put around work
have kind of expanded.
Some of that has been
driven by the fact that
some of these alternative
models are flexible for people,
useful for people, allow people
to complement their incomes
when they're not earning enough
from their full-time jobs.
So this variety of work
phenomena has also been changing
our work quite a bit.
So these were trends Sal
that were already underway
even before COVID.
They had already impacted sectors
like manufacturing, so if
you had gone to a factory
in 1980 versus a factory in
2018 it looked very different.
You probably wouldn't
see as many people there.
You'd probably seen a lot of robots
and machines assembling
things on the assembly line.
So this was already changing.
But I think one of the things
that as we look forward
that's become important
is that with the emergence
and progress in artificial
intelligence for example,
we're starting to see machines
that are capable of doing
some of those things
are we often associated
with human intelligence.
The ability to understand patterns,
the ability to think through some
kinds of classes of problems and so that,
the expansion and emergence
artificial intelligence has made
many people start to
worry about, so therefore
what will people do in the future.
So that's been one of the
trends we've been looking at
along with the varieties of work.
I should point out
though, sorry you're about
to ask something.
- No no no keep going.
I was gonna ask, all the
things you alluded to,
automation, artificial
intelligence, there's people
who can paint a very dystopian
future that most jobs
could get taken away.
I mean people talk about
self-driving cars and trucks
and even a lot of office work or even
AIs that can do deep learning
algorithms that are better
at diagnosing radiological
images better than radiologists.
Do you all see a future where
we have this mass displacement
of tens of millions of
people even in just the US
or do you think it's more gradual
and we shouldn't be so scared?
- Well we shouldn't be so
scared because one of the things
that actually happens is
that and I'll illustrate this
with a story.
So, you're a student of history Sal
and, so, many people may not know this but
in the 60s President
Lyndon Johnson put together
a commission which is a Blue
Ribbon Commission to look at
the future of work and
the role of automation.
One of the conclusions
in their report in 1967
where some of that's
always stuck with me and
what that conclusion was
that technology destroys jobs
but not work.
That is actually quite
important 'cause what happens
as we've seen both historically
but also looking forward
is that, yes there will
be some occupations
that will decline.
We don't have people driving
horse and buggies anymore.
We don't know if people
operate elevators anymore
except maybe in a few remaining places.
So some jobs will decline
but many more actually grow
and emerge because there's still
work that needs to be done.
So when you look at the
puts and takes if you like
much of the research
we've done and in fact
many other economists have done
and technologists have done
and he's talking of looking
at the next few decades
and these suggest that yes
while some jobs will be lost
there will also be jobs gained
meaning jobs that will grow
and emerge as a result of
new things that we'll do
in the economy.
So I like to think of this as
what we see with technology
and automation is a phenomena
of three kinds actually.
Yes some jobs lost, some jobs gained
but also many more jobs changed.
And the jobs changed
part is quite important.
Think about the things you
spend your day doing Sal.
Most occupations consist
of 20 30 different constituent activities.
Some of those are being replaced by
or those constituent actives
have been replaced by technology,
your job is still there.
You mentioned the radiologists.
If you look at what the
radiologists actually does
the amount of time that
they spent looking at images
is I think the number in
the US is something like 38%
is the time to actually
spend looking at images
there are other things that they do.
They are coordinating things,
they're doing research,
they're doing a whole
bunch of other things.
So that's an example where a
portion of their work changes.
Think about the bank teller now which is
a fascinating example.
If you had looked at a bank
teller in 1970 what did
they spend the majority
of their time doing?
Counting your money,
either to take it from you
when you give it to them
or to give it back to you
when you ask for it.
That was like 80% of their time.
Then the ATM showed up but you
don't need them to do that.
Do we still have bank tellers?
We do.
What do they do?
Quite different activities.
So if you look at the
amount of time bank tellers
are spending counting money
it's a tiny portion.
The rest of the time they're
doing customer service,
they're helping you think
about accounts you wanna open,
a whole bunch of things.
That's an example of a job
that's changed because of
the advent of technology.
So we'll see this phenomenon
of jobs lost, jobs gained
and jobs changed as in
important thing to keep in mind
as you think about the impact
of technology on our society.
- And what do you think, well
there's a bunch of questions
and even a few that
I'm seeing from YouTube
of just do a synopsis of some
of these is I think everyone,
I hear you but there's a general feeling
that artificial intelligence
might be different than just
the traditional forms of automation that
have happened before and that even if
it doesn't net kill work
does it change the equality
or inequality and this kind
of starts going into what
we're seeing with COVID, what
we're seeing with a lot of
the issues that COVID
might have only highlighted
around inequality, whether
it's around income around race
should we be afraid and is
kind of a lot of the tension
we're feeling almost
a byproduct of some of
these trends starting to really hit home.
- I think the question is an
important one to think about
because, well as I said before
I worried less about other,
is there gonna be work in the future?
'Cause I think there
will be net of the things
I've just described.
But there is something
I worry about, these are
a couple things I do worry about.
I do worry about impact
on incomes and wages
because, I'll illustrate
this as an example Sal.
Many of the hardest automate
occupations tend to be
so think about care work, for
example, it's very very hard
to fully automate that.
Think about some of the hardest,
many of those occupations
have tended to be
occupations that the wages
have not been great for actually.
So there's a worry that
even if we have enough work
it's possible that many of
the jobs won't pay very well
and that's something I do worry about and
that would actually
exacerbate the challenge that
we already have with inequality.
It's something that people
have worried about for
a long time.
You often hear politicians
say, we need good jobs back
Manufacturing jobs are good jobs,
it is true manufacturing
jobs have historically paid
quite well but that's
also where we've seen
a lot of automation,
whereas many of the jobs
that have grown in the service
sector have tended to be
not all of them but many of
them have tended to be jobs
that don't pay as well.
So yes the the income inequality
question is clearly one
that we should worry about.
The other one we should
worry about are the skills
and adaptation that people
are gonna have to go through.
So even if there is enough
work and people work alongside
the machines, that's gonna require
slightly different skills,
slightly different mix of skills
so how do we retrain everybody?
How do we keep people skills adaptable
as they end up working
alongside technology?
So these issues of skills and adaptation
and the income questions
are things that do worry me.
I worry less about, will there be jobs?
I worry more about, will they
be the right kind of jobs
and how do we tackle equality?
Now many of these issues we've
often talked about them Sal
as the future of work.
Well in some ways COVID
has kind of accelerated
all of that and it's now
kind of here and maybe
that's something we should talk about it.
What are we seeing around
work in this moment.
- Right.
I mean there's from Facebook
we have this question
from Matthew Kavanagh, is AI
making it impossible to predict
the future of work and work patterns?
Several people have kind of
alluded to what should they do
with their life I'm assuming
they're their high school
or college students and
you're absolutely right.
COVID has, there's kind of
these two worlds people like me
and you who can for the most
part continue to do our work
from our home offices
and then a lot of people
in service industries and
wherever else where they can't
and it's made inequality maybe worse.
So what advice would you give
and what trends do you think
from COVID are real and that we really do
have to struggle with.
- Well, I think it's important
before we get to what we do
about it to actually fully
understand what's been exposed
with regards to work and inequality
by this COVID moment.
So right now for example if
you look at the US workforce,
something like about 1/3 workers that
I would call vulnerable
and let me describe
what I mean by vulnerability.
These are workers who are vulnerable
to layoffs or to being furloughed
or experiencing reduced hours
and income as a result of both
either public safety concerns
about health or the fact that
their sector that they work
in has essentially shut down.
So for example if you happen
to work in their restaurant
for example or in the travel
industry, where there isn't
a whole lot going on right now.
So a third of the US
workforce that's vulnerable
in that sense.
That's a very large number.
Now if you look at the profile
of who those workers are
it's something like 80% of them
are low wage workers meaning
that they earn less than $40,000 a year.
So it's disproportionately impacting
low-income workers the most.
And a large portion of them
don't have college degrees
or college education, 80% of
them actually and many of them
are disproportionately people of color,
black and brown people.
So, if there was already
inequality in an educational sense
or in an or wage sense or in
a kind of demographic sense
we're seeing it in full-blown force.
And those are people as you said Sal
many of those occupations
you can't do them remotely
in the way you and I can do what we do
because we know that
something like almost 45% of
those vulnerable workers,
their work has to be done
in some physical place somewhere.
You can't do it over ZOOM
or whatever technology
you happen to be using.
So that's a real concern.
So the question is what
do we do about that?
I think lots of things.
First was to solve for the
public health concerns because
a lot of the people who are most exposed
in the public health
sense have tended to be
many of those same workers.
We also have to, so we have to solve
for their health safety.
Give them the right
equipment PPE and so forth
and making sure that
they're protected if they
have to go out to do work.
But the other thing is to think
about how do we supplement
their incomes and help
them and support them?
So some of the stimulus checks
or the unemployment insurance
checks have helped a lot.
But one of the things
we're realizing is that
because we have a system
where a lot of the access
to health services or
benefits are tied to employers
well if employers shut
things down we've essentially
potentially cut off people
from some of the health
and other benefits that
they might have got.
So that's exposing the
difficulty when we've got
a benefit system that's
inherently tied to employment.
So these are some of the
things we have to tackle
if we're gonna support those
exposed and vulnerable workers.
- And do you think there's some limit to
I mean this is goes into more from
the macro economics question
that I've asked other guests
but trillion here trillion
there starts to add up
at some point.
What do you think is the limit at which
the government won't
be able to write checks
to hold people over essentially?
- Well this is the classic
difficulty of balancing
the short term and the long term.
So in the short term sense I
would say let's help people
as much as we can because
that's the challenge
that's here and now.
Those are workers we need to
support an economy, (mumbling)
support who are exposed the
public health sense right now
and also in an economic sense right now.
So we have to protect their
lives and livelihoods.
This is something we've
been writing a lot about.
How do we protect lives and
livelihoods in this moment.
But it also then has this
other long-term consequence
which is because the way the
economic system gets to write
those checks or trillion
here trillion there is that
in some ways we're borrowing
from the future if you like
in a way.
So this is the tough combination
but personally I would say
let's tackle the issues that are right
in front of us right now which is people
who are exposed, whose lives are exposed
and whose livelihoods are exposed.
So anything we can do to help them I think
is fundamentally important.
- Right, right, and what
I've, the general sense
I've been hearing and even
when I think about myself is
the Fed is aggressive that
helps lower interest rates,
they're essentially printing
money and then the government
can borrow at record low interest
rates and really the risk
in the short to medium term is
inflation which doesn't seem
if anything deflation because
of all the other trends
you talked about like automation,
it might be a bigger risk.
- Oh it would be so in fact
one of the other challenges
we're facing by the way
as I mentioned there's
a lot of workers were exposed right now,
they're vulnerable because
they can't work and so forth.
Well we know ready that something like 40%
of those occupations also our occupations
that are at risk of automation.
So the interplay of these dynamics
is really really important.
But I think one of the things
many of us are concluding
is that we kind of have
two simultaneously solve
these two things which
is, how do we deal with
the public health crisis that
we've got at the same time
we're finding safe ways
to keep the economy
and reopen the economy
and those two things
kind of go hand to hand.
I think the challenge we've
got practically is that
we're running 50 experiments
if you like in fact more
than that in the sense that
every state is kind of doing
their own thing in fact
it's more than that
because even within states
you find some cities
some counties are doing things
a little bit differently.
That actually makes it very
complicated and in fact raises
the potential that we're gonna
be kind of in this bumpy road
for a while and recovery will
probably take even longer
because we're kind of
waiting on the one hand
for the public health crisis
to abate or be under control
and waiting for vaccines and
you had Bill Gates talking
about that, we're waiting
for therapies but also we
need safe ways to reopen
and we're trying to reopen and
get the economy, so I worry
that we're gonna be in this
mode of kind of small steps,
bumpy steps back and forth
and forward hopefully for
quite a while, for longer
than we would like.
And that's a worry.
- And then related to this and I do think
it is somewhat related.
I don't think it's a coincidence
that we're seeing the
kind of mass protests
in, when you already had
this COVID happening in the background
but you've had obviously
the murder of George Floyd
which has kind of reinvigorated
or really opened up conversations
around systemic racism, police brutality,
I'm curious your point of
view obviously personally,
how it affects you and your
family but also as someone
who thinks systematically
about business and jobs,
there's a fear that a
lot of companies are,
they do lip service to
the notions of diversity
and inclusivity but at the end of the day
behind closed doors will say
well but it's a harder problem,
they'll talk about the
pipeline problem or it starts.
Maybe it's Khan Academy's
problem 'cause we have to start
with students when they're
in pre-k in elementary school
and all that.
How do you think about it?
I mean how are you think about it?
Personally, what do you think
has to change so that we don't
keep repeating this, and
how do you think the role
of the business community, what
action should they be taking
to not just do lip service?
- Well these are really big
questions Sal as you know
but you asked about the personal,
my own personal experience
and I've lived in the United
States now for about 20 years
and I can tell you these issues affect me
and affect everyone.
One of the things that's
been surprising to me is the,
even when people understand
things there's the presumption
that oh it happens to
those people over there,
poor disadvantaged people of color
but I think it happens
to all people of color.
So let me give you some
personal experience.
It doesn't matter, I'm fairly privileged,
I'm lucky to do the things
that I do and so forth but
that doesn't stop the police stopping me
occasionally, which happens.
It doesn't stop showing up
at work in Silicon Valley,
showing up at a company to say
I'm here to meet with the CEO
and I'm told, oh you can
leave it here, right?
The presumption being there
to deliver something, right?
So, it happens to all of us.
There isn't a a black male
in this country who apart
from people perhaps who are
recognizably celebrities,
there's the black male I
know, CEO down to the janitor
who hasn't got a story to
tell you about some experience
that they've had in the store somewhere,
so this happens to all of us
and we're constantly thinking about that.
I worry about I'm the
father of a young black man.
I worry about it when he goes out.
So these are very personal issues.
But I think zooming out from
the personal, I think perhaps
what we're seeing is, these
have been issues that have been
there for a very long time
and it's a combination I think
perhaps this moment was a
bit of a boiling over point
with the death of George Floyd
that kind of brought things
to a fall, but these issues of inequity,
systemic inequities, both in the, not just
in the policing and
criminal justice system
but in society,
economically, have persisted
for a very long time.
And I think what I'm hopeful
is that maybe this time things
will be different and people start to take
address them directly.
I've been quite encouraged, we'll see,
but I've been encouraged by
the fact that there's been
a bit of a collective chorus
of recognition of these issues
not universal of course but
at least a larger chorus
than before, and I see it both in the,
inside large companies
in the private sector,
in foundations and in the social sector.
So that chorus I think is encouraging.
I'm also seeing it go beyond just a chorus
but people starting to propose actions
that they're gonna take.
There's some easy actions.
Important but easy actions.
The easy actions I think for
companies is to write a check.
So donate to this cause and that cause
and fund this fund that.
That's great, it's happening and I think
many will benefit that way.
The harder thing is to
actually change organizations.
Change for example leadership,
change attitudes towards
these issues, change hiring
practices, address some of the
biased questions that affect candidates
when they're applying for jobs and work.
Those are much harder things to do.
But I think people are
committing to doing those so
I'm hopeful, I'm optimistic in that sense.
- And just even from your
vantage point as one of
the senior leaders at
McKinsey which is for those
who don't know McKinsey it
is kind of considered kind of
the elite of the elite in terms
of strategy consulting firms
and you all are the advisors
to CEOs and governments
around the world.
So a lot of ways you'll
have influence with a lot of
other entities and then
also what y'all obviously do
with your own organization,
do you see that there
there will be change?
And what are those levers?
If you have to pick
your top three levers on
any of these issues.
Obviously there's the
police brutality issue which
we might have limited control over.
That's kind of a sheriff
government police union type issue.
But in the corporate sector
what levers would you?
- Well I think in the corporate sector
it's committing to the kind of inclusivity
that we're talking about.
I mean for those who are
interested even we at McKinsey
have actually put out 10
actions that we're gonna take
and some of the harder
ones in the private sector
for many of us is to make
sure we recruit differently,
we hire differently, we
address issues of bias
and help people progress.
We make sure people are being
mentored and have allies.
I mean this is one of those things where,
the people of color can't just
work on this by themselves.
I think there's a sense of a
need for collective ownership
of the fact that we do
want to hire differently.
We do want to look at
candidates across the board.
We do wanna look at people's skills.
We do wanna look at how do
we support people progress?
Those are some of the more
kind of cultural things
to think about.
I think there's some
wonderful work and research
that was done by Claude Steele.
So Claude was the provost
at Berkeley and Colombia.
Before that he was a
professor at Stanford.
About this issue of stereotyping
and bias in how we coach
each other, support each other.
I mean you're a teacher
and you're educating people
but even the way a learner
and their teacher or if it's
a worker, a worker and their
supervisor who's coaching
and mentoring them, paying
attention to these things
makes enormous difference.
It makes enormous difference.
So many corporations and
we're doing it ourselves
going through training
about systemic bias,
how do you watch for that?
How do you make sure in
the coaching and mentoring
you're not inadvertently
kind of biasing the feedback
and the learning?
That's the hard work that
we're all gonna have to do
and we at McKinsey I know have
as much work to do as anybody.
We don't have enough
black leaders at McKinsey.
We don't have enough people
of color coming through
in the organization.
We're all working hard at it.
So we've made a commitment to
double for example leadership
in our firm at all levels
in four years or less.
That's gonna be hard for us.
But that's a big commitment we're making.
- Yeah.
And going back to I mean
there's a ton of questions
that are coming in and these
conversations always go faster
than I expect 'cause there's
so much to talk about.
I mean you know there's a couple
of questions people are asking.
I mean going back to
the work question about
what should people do
with their lives given the uncertainty?
There's there's questions about,
what do you think are going to be
the permanent effects of COVID
but I would extend it,
COVID and a lot of what
we just talked about.
There's a very particular
question from Facebook about
what do you think about Trump's
H1B policy, the Visa policy.
I'd like to take it where
you'd like to take it James
in the few minutes we have left.
- Yeah, so it's worth
talking perhaps about
what's gonna be permanent post-COVID maybe
as trends that people can
anticipate as people think about
what to do, how we adapt and adjust.
I think we've seen ourselves go through
some rapid global experiments.
We've experimented with
the work from home.
We've experimented from remote learning
and people have, more people
that are already using Khan Academy
have discovered Khan Academy,
(laughing) thankfully,
in this moment and
that's a wonderful thing
but I think many of those
things aren't gonna change.
I think we've seen the benefits
of some of those things.
We've seen the the value some people have
from working from home, the flexibility
but some people wanna go back to work.
So the workplace itself I think
is gonna look quite different.
The learning environment I think
I think we've learned that
we may be in a no contact
or at least a low contact economy.
I think some of the experiences
of social distancing
and avoiding density,
I'm not sure all of those
will go away.
I think we've seen a growth
in telehealth, for example.
People being more comfortable doing
health consultations remotely.
I think much of that is gonna stay.
So those are things that I
think are gonna be with us
for a while.
To the question of how
can one adapt and learn?
I think, it's one thing I
love about Khan Academy,
I think that being in a mode where
we are perpetually learning
and augmenting our skills
and what we know, I think
it's just gonna become
a lifelong skill.
Learning to learn and
learning to adapt permanently
and perpetually is one thing.
The other thing I would
also add is, we're gonna see
the importance of both skills,
not just the STEM skills
but also even some of the artistic skills
and I think it's gonna be the combination
of these other social skills
with some what some people
have called STEAM, right,
by adding A to STEM,
A for the arts.
I think that combination
is gonna be quite important
and those who have both kinds
of combinations of skills
I think are gonna do well.
So those would be the
two things I'd emphasize.
Constantly learning and having
this duality between STEM
and artistic and social skills I think
it's gonna be quite important.
- Yeah, and I always find
STEAM entertaining because
it really just means being
a well-rounded human being.
(both laughing)
'Cause it's covering everything.
- Exactly, exactly, exactly.
- Well James, unfortunately
we're all out of time
considering you're a board
member I consider it your duty
to do this again.
(laughing) Hopefully we can
have more of these conversations
'cause I think we just
started scratching the surface
on a lot of this especially
even the future of work
et cetera et cetera, so,
thank you James so much for
joining and I hope we do
do get to do this in
another couple of weeks.
- Well thank you for having
me and, welcome support
from those watching Khan Academy.
It's a wonderful wonderful
resource, so thank you.
- Thanks James.
So thanks everyone for joining.
As you can see just another
fascinating conversation.
James is a big hero of mine and someone
I definitely look up to
and is a great board member
for Khan Academy.
And I look forward to not only
bringing him on in the future
but we have many other really
interesting guests coming up
and I will see you at future live streams.
See you all later.